bonjour François Patriat bonjour vous
êtes notre invité politique ce matin
vous êtes la sénateur de Côte-d'Or
président du groupe RDPI au Sénat le
groupe des sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale qui
est représentée aujourd'hui par Fabrice
Weisser Redon rédacteur en chef au bras
le groupe des journaux de l'Est de la
France bonjour Fabrice
le retour sur le terrain d'Emmanuel
Macron hier en Alsace une visite qui a
été chahutée on a vu un président de la
République accueilli sous les hués sous
les bruits de casseroles ça montre
qu'Emmanuel Macron ne peut plus aller au
contact des Français ça montre qu'il
peut y aller puisqu'il y est d'aller il
est difficilement non mais c'est pas la
première fois que c'est difficile pour
le président ce n'est que j'ai fait la
grande itinérance avec lui j'ai fait
juste avant la crise des gilets jaunes
déplacements ensuite pendant les gilets
jaunes avec lui j'étais faire le grand
débat je suis allé dans plusieurs
départements avec lui c'était jamais
facile c'est toujours été compliqué en
l'occurrence là je crois que le
président a raison d'abord il veut
montrer qu'il peut sortir de l'Elysée
imaginez qu'il sorte pas aujourd'hui ils
vont dire regardez il est bunkerisé il
n'ose pas sortir voilà le président
prisonnier qui voit maintenant il va au
contact du terrain il est allé hier
visiter une entreprise on a vu quoi on a
vu de France on a vu une France dans une
entreprise qui innove qui exporte qui
construit qui crée des emplois créent la
richesse que n'a vu des gens à côté dans
le village qui cognait sur des
casseroles jambes on a le droit de
manifester je leur conteste pas ce droit
mais depuis le début
de la réforme de retraite je vois ces
deux France tout le temps moi j'habite
en territoire rural je vois une France
qui travaille tous les jours qui
manifeste pas qu'il n'est pas dans la
rue qui sans doute n'est pas pour la
réforme des retraites mais qui est dans
le même temps continue à faire avancer
ce pays avec la bouger puis à d'autres
qui semaine après semaine viennent
manifester d'ailleurs on ne proposant
qu'une seule chose il y a pas de
l'alternative il y a pas de proposition
c'est retrait du texte retrait du texte
le chef de l'État a dit dans
l'accompagne électorale que ce texte
serait non seulement voté il avait dit
65 nous avons fait des avancées il y a
eu des concessions jamais les sensations
on a fait des concessions dessus bon
ensuite et ensuite il a dit que ce texte
serait appliqué pour l'été ce texte sera
appliqué pour l'été alors Emmanuel
Macron a répliqué en disant que ce ne
sont pas les casseroles qui vont faire
avancer la France est-ce que c'est une
réplique qui est dans l'apaisement comme
il l'a appelé de ses vœux lundi dans son
allocution est-ce que vous trouvez que
le concert de cree dû lui et d'insultes
que partie des manifestants alimentaires
sont dans l'apaisement trouver alors il
faudrait qu'il reste là sans rien dire
sans dire mais vous avez raison taper
sur des casseroles vous ne voulez pas
m'écouter vous ne voulez pas m'entendre
vous tapez sur les sacs casseroles
pourquoi lundi soir parce que vous ne
voulez pas qu'on m'écoute dans le même
temps vous voudriez que vous prenez
l'apaisement non pas du tout je crois
qu'il y a une partie des syndicats à
tous qui veulent maintenir une partie de
bras de fer bon écoutez je vais pas dire
on les entend on les écoute puisque ils
ne veulent pas nous écouter mais ils ont
le droit de manifester et la France a le
droit d'avancer dans une interview que
Emmanuel Macron nous a accordé au groupe
Ebra dans quatre de cette visite en
Alsace il déclare en état marche forcée
en particulier cette dernière année
qu'est-ce que ça dit que la situation
d'être à Marge forcé ça veut dire qu'il
avait dit à un moment il avait dit vous
savez la France et dur à réformer
pour faire des réformes qui vont dans le
sens plutôt de d'acquis sociaux et
autres tout va bien dès qu'il s'agit
est-ce qu'on peut avancer d'une manière
apaisée quand on est dans une marche
forte est-ce que non mais à partir du
moment où une partie des gens disent bah
nous on veut pas on n'accepte pas de
faire des efforts de prendre une partie
supplémentaire à partir de ce moment-là
où il dit il y a un blocage de leur part
si on veut avancer je dis pas que la
marque forcée mais il faut avancer en
continuant sur le programme et après on
peut quand même pas reprocher
aujourd'hui au président d'appliquer le
programme qu'il a proposé pendant la
campagne électorale parce que quand on
me dit je l'ai déjà dit mais quand on me
dit que la réforme des retraites c'est
pas dans la campagne si le jour où
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé qu'il était
pour 65 ans il a perdu 5 points dans les
sondages juste les gens l'ont entendu
juste à propos de la loi Emmanuel Macron
a demandé au ministre une liste de enfin
Elisabeth borne a demandé au ministre
précisément une liste d'actions qui
peuvent être réalisées rapidement sans
passer par la voix mais par la voix du
décret et c'est une liste qui doit être
rendue rapidement qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous en tant que parlementaire je
pense que vous savez quand vous voulez
prendre des décisions sur des sujets du
concret du quotidien
si vous passez par une loi il y en a
pour deux ans le temps que la loi passe
au côté des ministres qu'elle soit votée
au Sénat à l'assemblée que les décrets
sortent ensuite etc avec les délais
pour certaines lois un an et demi
si vous voulez faire bouger les choses
dans le domaine de l'école un domaine de
la dhitale dans le domaine des
transports vous pouvez le faire par
décret à partir du moment où la
Constitution dit bien que ça nécessite
pas une loi moi j'y vois des avantages
tu vois les avantages c'est celui de
l'efficacité les décrets en général ne
sont pas pris ex ni l'eau comme ça ils
sont pris après concertation on l'a vu
pour la loi travail et pour d'autres
donc des déconcles préalable c'est la
concertation voilà je pense aujourd'hui
mais on l'a fait vous savez quand
j'entends dire que sur ce texte de loi
il y a pas il y a pas eu de discussion
de négociation il y a eu six mois de
négociations de discussion c'est pas
vrai jamais loi n'a été autant concertée
que c'est ça mais en tout cas le
président de la République a refusé de
recevoir les syndicats pendant cette
période de crise de la réforme des
retraites et notamment d'abord il les
avait reçu avant ils avaient reçu après
son élection ils ont été reçus dans le
cadre du CNR ils ont été reçus par
Matignon la demande qui était faite fin
mars c'était retiré le texte il n'avait
qu'une seule demande à partir du moment
où le président avait décidé avec le
gouvernement avec la majorité
que ce texte devait être voté où était
l'utilité d'avoir une rencontre avec les
syndicats qui lui disait il y a rien
d'autre à faire que de retirer le texte
donc pour vous c'était normal de fermer
la porte de l'Elysée à Laurent Berger
justement une question sur Laurent
Berger le patron de la CFDT qui a
annoncé hier et qu'il quitterait ses
fonctions en juin une annonce qui est
intervient en pleine crise de la réforme
des retraites est-ce que finalement ce
départ de Laurent Berger ce n'est pas
une bonne nouvelle pour Emmanuel Macron
pour la majorité présidentielle je crois
qu'il y a le président a dit qu'il avait
de l'estime pour ce berger c'était
quelqu'un qui était responsable
d'ailleurs il fait preuve de
responsabilité il a dit manifestera pas
nous après après le passage de la loi on
respectera la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel ce que n'ont pas fait
les parties d'extrême gauche là ici en
particulier qui conteste la légitimité
il a dit ensuite bien entendu qu'il y
aurait un premier mai très mobilisateur
il appelle avast mobilisé il dit que le
combat n'est pas fini parce que il pense
encore que le rip que le rip peut
intervenir on verra la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel le 3 mai dans le
même temps je pense que c'est c'est un
réformiste Laurent Berger c'est
quelqu'un qui est mais je crois qu'il
avait fait 200 l'engagement au Congrès
récemment dernier congrès de la tlu le
fait qu'il n'était contre les mesures
d'âge il l'a dit il l'a tenu on en a
tenu compte il a il a eu ce message
jusqu'au bout moi peut-être je dirais je
dirais je reviens sur ce mot parce que
il a beaucoup parlé de mépris pendant
ces derniers jours et ça je pense qu'on
ne peut pas dire que c'est pas vrai le
président ne méprise pas les Français ça
ne l'entend pas comme tel si c'est
mépris si quand si quand il y a un
concert de casserole on dit bah écoutez
il y a quelqu'un jalousine de casseroles
c'est du mépris alors il faut se taire à
chaque fois qu'on est construit ou
insulté mais je crois que le président a
raison d'avoir le courage d'aller au
contact de montrer d'abord qu'il peut
sortir et surtout hier on l'a vu
dialoguer certes de façon
forte avec une syndicaliste de linsol il
a discuté mais quand même il a dit il a
redit pourquoi il fallait et il a dit
sur tout pourquoi il fallait faire la
loi et la redire surtout quelle était la
voix à suivre pour que le pays avance
pour revenir alors héberger une petite
seconde une question de connexe c'est
une femme Marylise Léon qui devrait lui
succéder au mois de juin c'est déjà le
cas assez GT puisque Sophie Binet a pris
les manettes du syndicat on a le cas à
Matignon dans le cas à l'assemblée sont
des femmes qui ont pris le pouvoir le
Sénat dernier carré masculin le côté il
est pas il me semble pour le Sénat quand
je vois la configuration les candidats
putatif vous venez d'avoir tout à
l'heure monsieur Bacher devant vous il
me semble que le président Larcher qui
dispose d'une large majorité où je ne
crois pas aujourd'hui les élections
sénatoriales ne bourse l'air seront pas
l'équilibre du Sénat je vois pas le
président de l'archi aujourd'hui qui dit
qu'il est en campagne pour le Sénat
demain laisser sa place à une femme
demain mais bien sûr que j'espère un
jour que l'ancienna il y aura une femme
qui sera d'ailleurs vous savez que avec
la proportionnelle au Sénat à partir de
3 sénateurs par habitant le nombre de
femmes a beaucoup progressé c'est pas
comme l'Assemblée nationale parce que
c'est différent le mode d'élection mais
là beaucoup de progressé je ne doute pas
qu'un jour il y a une présidente du
Sénat oui François Patriot on continue à
parler du dialogue social puisque
Emmanuel Macron a cette fois-ci ouvert
la porte de l'Elysée au syndicat pour
évoquer des mesures sur le travail et
notamment pour discuter durant cette
année d'un pacte sur la vie au travail
vous pensez que ce dialogue social est
encore possible après cette séquence de
la réforme des retraites moi je crois
que même s'il y a des femmes à la tête
de la CGT et ailleurs ça ou ailleurs je
pense que le rôle des syndicats c'est de
défendre l'intérêt des salariés et les
travailleurs
et qu'à partir du moment où les sujets
vont être qui vont être abordés mais qui
prennent du temps parce que vous savez
on a beaucoup dit vous avez fait vous
avez le processus à l'envers il aurait
fallu parler du travail avant les
retraites mais les dossiers de
négociation et le président l'a dit il
fait confiance aux partenaires sociaux
pour négocier sur ces sujets entre eux
ça prend beaucoup de beaucoup de temps
et si on l'avait fait sur l'emploi des
seniors sur la pénibilité sur l'autre la
loi elle aurait été votée peut-être en
2026 parce que regarder ring sur le
partage de la valeur sur la partage de
la valeur pour arriver à un accord qui
va être traduit qui va être traduit la
loi par la première ministre il a fallu
sept mois rien que sur le battage de la
valeur alors imaginez sur tous les
autres sujets et moi je pense que les
sujets qui intéressent la pénibilité les
carrières longues les cari arrachées à
nouveau revenir sur le sur en plus le
revenu au travail le partage de la
valeur sont des sujets qui qui prennent
du temps et je ne vois pas comment les
syndicats aujourd'hui pourraient ne pas
s'en saisir
la sécurité de la guerre à côté c'est
pas si facile d'avancer mais avancer et
quand on avance on a une immédiatement
une réponse à une question cuisante de
l'ensemble des salariés et le pouvoir
d'achat lorsque plus on va vers le plein
emploi plus la tension c'est les
embauchemontaient plus les salaires ont
on l'a vu dans le dans la restauration
quand il y a quand il y a des impôts en
tension les salaires vont
automatiquement et c'est bien ce
qu'elles veulent je pense les salariés
le poids d'achat qui a été une question
un petit peu absente de la location du
président quelle mesure va-t-il mettre
en oeuvre concrètement dans cette
période pour pouvoir d'achat des
Français qui n'est pas question
aujourd'hui de refaire des chèques comme
c'était fait nécessairement par le passé
contre l'inflation le gouvernement agit
avec beaucoup de milliards je pense
notamment au bouclier énergétique où les
Français globalement contre l'inflation
la France est le pays qui a le mieux
résisté puisque nous sommes à 5 7 là où
d'autres pays sont ainsi 7 8 9 bien
reste l'inflation sur l'alimentation qui
est dû au cours des matières premières
alors là ce que je pense c'est que dans
ce domaine en matière de pouvoir d'achat
il faut changer les règles là aussi
d'autres pays le font il faut que la
discussion entre les distributeurs les
industriels producteurs se fassent en
permanence sur l'année de façon à ce que
dès que les prix des cours baissent
pensent au cours du blé au cours
aujourd'hui du tournesol ou qui ont
baissé immédiatement ça serait percute
on voit bien que sur l'essence le gasoil
ça se fait pas naturellement aussi comme
ça il y a l'ascenseur et l'escalier vous
savez ça montre comment l'ascenseur ça
descend comme un escalier mais là
d'autres pays le font il y a d'ailleurs
une chaîne j'ai vu hier une chaîne de
distribution française qui elle le fait
en permanence avec les les producteurs
locaux et industriels locaux je pense
que dans ce domaine on peut avancer donc
la main il y aura pas d'annonce fort
d'annonces nouvelles sur le plan il peut
peut-être y avoir des baisses de
cotisation des baisses de charge qui
peut m'intervenir c'est une solution
mais le chèque pour maintenant je pense
que vous l'avez compris à mettre en
œuvre rapidement la réforme du RSA
c'est-à-dire conditionner le versement
du RSA à 15 à 20h d'activité pour les
bénéficiaires est-ce que ça ne va pas
crisper encore plus le pays
ecoutez moi je pense que il y a beaucoup
de Français notamment les classes
moyennes qui me disent tous les jours
c'est le sénateur moi je vois je bosse
tous les jours j'ai pas le droit au
chèque j'ai pas le droit aux aides j'ai
pas eu mes impôts je bénéficie donc plus
tard et dans le même temps il y a des
gens qui chaque jour et c'est bien
normal moi j'étais le sucre qui avait
voté le RMI vous savez je me souviens
quand on a voté le RMI c'est passé à
100%
quand on a voté
dans une motion de censure bon là vous
voyez la différence tout à l'heure quand
je disais le blocage
mais dans le RMI il y avait déjà
insertion et aujourd'hui on demande aux
gens qui vont donc bénéficier de cette
aide qui est normal on leur verse c'est
un dû contrepartie il y est un aller
vers l'emploi allez vers l'emploi c'est
faire des stages c'est faire du travail
d'acceptif à côté c'est d'aller dans les
entreprises et se former savoir un
accompagnement pour se faire à partir du
moment où on dit on va multiplier les
moyens donner les moyens supplémentaires
à France travail pour accompagner moins
de chômeurs qui donne aujourd'hui moins
de gens au RSA on va les accompagner
mieux je crois que qui peut aujourd'hui
moi je suis pour vous avez la
controverse positive est-ce que est-ce
que les est-ce que les Français ou
est-ce que les chômeurs sont contre le
fait d'être mieux accompagnés de pouvoir
rentrer dans l'entreprise de pouvoir se
former de pouvoir passer c'est le permis
de conduire pour pouvoir accéder à
l'emploi est-ce que c'est pas la méthode
rationnelle la plus efficace donc pour
vous il faut mettre en oeuvre cette
réforme du RSA rapidement on va parler
trop de social François Patriat puisque
le ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire
a lancé une polémique mardi en évoquant
c'est personne qui frôle les prestations
sociales et qui envoie l'argent vers le
Maghreb est-ce qu'il a eu raison de
tenir ce type de propos je crois moi
j'écoute président de la République
alors que ce que nous l'avons vu lundi
après-midi il a dit parmi les mesures à
prendre aujourd'hui il faut lutter
contre toutes les fraudes non pas que le
faute soit la panacée à la recette
universelle de main mais quand même on a
vu que les efforts qui ont été faits par
le gouvernement pour récupérer cela
fraude je crois que ça c'est la semaine
dernière ça donne l'année dernière ça
doit être 12 ou 13 milliards je crois
que ça sur l'année 2022 donc ça n'est
pas rien il y a déjà une lutte contre la
fraude maintenant bien entendu que la
plus grande fraude dans ce pays elle est
faite par tous ceux qui bénéficient
j'allais dire des statuts fiscales etc
l'optimisation fiscale
on appelle ça aujourd'hui c'est pas
légal mais bon il y a des gens qui font
pas réellement mais il y a aussi des
gens qui vous disent attention parce que
moi à côté de chez moi moi je travaille
tous les jours avec ma femme on y arrive
on est juste au dessus du SMIC on a deux
voitures on bosse puis il y a des gens
qui à côté qui est à côté euh
s'installe dans le RSA ne souhaite pas
en sortir c'est bon
stigmatisé les gens qui vont agréable je
suis pas sûr que ce soit la bonne
méthode donc que les choses soient
claires que les choses soient claires
mais malgré tout moi je toi tous ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui que on est en
train de diviser les Français moi je je
vais quand même pas cru comprendre que
les gens de gauche étaient pour la
fraude
j'espère pas en tout cas je pense pas
non non les gens de gauche actuellement
s'indignes sur le fait de pointer du
doigt ces personnes originaires du
Maghreb de citer le Maghreb est-ce que
ce n'est pas un clin d'oeil à la droite
et à l'électorat du RN que souhaite
faire Bruno Le Maire et l'exécutif il y
a beaucoup de gens qui sont pas heureux
qui votent pas RN et qui vous disent il
y a des gens je stigmatise pas je veux
pas stigmatiser mais qui aujourd'hui
bénéficie alors que il y a d'ailleurs un
département qui est voisin du bien que
j'aime bien la Haute-Saône dont le
président il se gratte un G a mis en
place déjà depuis longtemps trois ans ou
4 ans une commission du juste droit
à une Commission d'examiner tous les
gens qui sont au RSA et de voir si
effectivement ils ont droit et où où
vont les aide ils demandent où est-ce
que les aides il le fait bon cette
méthode là qu'il faut prendre le
stigmatison personne aujourd'hui il y a
des dérives en la matière il y en a
elles sont mineurs elles existent malgré
tout
la gauche du constigmatise aujourd'hui
je pense que si la gauche que j'ai
soutenue à laquelle je partirai de coeur
aujourd'hui avait été aussi efficace
pour l'emploi et pour la lutte contre la
fraude ça serait vu à ce moment-là sur
la question de l'immigration François
Patriat le ministre de l'Intérieur veut
relancer son projet loi immigration qui
avait été reporté par le Président de la
République à cause de la crise de la
réforme des retraites et ce qu'il y aura
toujours un seul projet de loi
immigration présenté au Parlement j'ai
cru comprendre et c'est ce qui a été
évoqué lors de la rencontre avec le
président lundi que c'était plutôt un
texte un texte alors j'entends d'abord
dans ce texte on dirait un mot quel est
l'objet de texte il est permette de
mieux maîtriser les flux migratoires
d'une part et d'autre part
permettre de mieux renvoyer dans leur
pays les occitf aujourd'hui qu'on le
fait actuellement obligations
expéditif sur le renvoi exocqf la gauche
durable qu'on est trop difficile et
stigmatiseur à côté de ce qui rentre les
immigrés il faudra trouver un poids
d'équilibre et c'est l'objet de
discussion que mène cette semaine la
première ministre avec les groupes
politiques il se dit dans l'entourage du
président que la question d'immigration
sera l'une des priorités de la suite de
ce quinquennat nous confirmait
moi j'ai pas entendu j'ai pas entendu ça
c'est Jour Dernier je pense que
l'immigration c'est une priorité depuis
longtemps
sur l'immigration moi ce que je souhaite
c'est pas tant qui est une loi c'est
qu'une loi dans les mesures ne soit pas
stigmatisante ne soit efficace je
souhaite qu'effectivement on puisse
mieux maîtriser les flux que le droit
des îles quand j'ai vu les propositions
de la droite qui aujourd'hui supprimait
l'aide médicale d'urgence et qui veut
supprimer le groupement familial qui
veut etc qui veut que les gens qui
viennent en France parlent très bien le
français etc bon c'est mieux connaître
la situation réelle de ce qui est le
continent africain aujourd'hui donc faut
pas dire ça comme ça des mesures ce que
je souhaite c'est que ce texte est je
l'ai dit lundi d'ailleurs disait j'ai
dit ok pour ma texte immigration un
texte qui donne des résultats voilà
c'est ça qui m'intéresse est-ce que la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier qui était prévu à l'origine dans
ce texte au départ sera toujours dans
cette loi immigration alors la
régularisation elle est faite pour les
gens qui ont un emploi sur les métiers
en tension je pense c'est une bonne une
bonne mesure effectivement il y a déjà
beaucoup de gens qui sont ici en France
aujourd'hui qui auraient du travail qui
serait embauché j'ai des patrons qui
m'appellent en disant mais je me suis un
tel et là je veux l'embaucher comment je
peux faire etc je pense c'est une façon
de créer de la richesse dans ce pays et
de transformer des immigrés en citoyens
plus actifs pour le pays mais vous savez
si elle sera conservée par Gérald de
Darmanin dans son texte j'espère
on va parler politique François Patriat
puisque Emmanuel Macron dans son
allocution a annoncé qu'il voulait
réformer les institutions pour redonner
un nouveau souffle à la démocratie et
aujourd'hui dans son interview donnée
aux journaux de l'Est de la France il
est indiqué qu'il utilisera le
référendum sur des sujets de son choix
c'est la bonne méthode sur quel sujet
doit-il l'utiliser bah écoutez c'est une
proposition que j'ai fait justement
lundi
brève intervention
on a évoqué les sujets que vous venez
d'évoquer maintenant les cultures lois
et à la fois je dis que le référendum
est un bon outil
vous avez rencontré
président de groupe de la majorité avec
les ministres on a rencontré le chef de
l'État bon et je peux en parler comme ça
et moi j'ai dit que il fallait il
fallait utiliser un fandom redonner la
parole au peuple mais pas sur une
question êtes-vous pour ou contre devant
plus de retraite parce que si on connaît
la réponse avant ça c'est facile le
sujet de la loi alors moi j'ai proposé
on pourrait faire un référendum sur la
fin de vie je pense que c'est un sujet
sur lequel on peut interroger les
Français c'est un sujet de société
profond et là on est pas difficile
contre difficile
du débat qui a eu
dans la convention citoyenne et des
propositions qui sont faites qui peuvent
déboucher sur un modèle français ce sera
un modèle français d'aide à la fin de
vie ça me paraît être un sujet sur
lequel on peut interroger les Français
sur les institutions on peut leur
réformer aussi êtes-vous pour ou contre
la diminution du nombre de
parlementaires l'Allemagne vient de le
faire là à ce moment elle vient de le
faire et pourquoi pas que le Président
de la République a une oreille
pour l'instant la droite ne donne pas de
signe de vouloir passer de contrat de
gouvernement avec nous il y a plusieurs
scénarios possibles il y a des scénarios
qui diraient on va on va accorder tel
texte non je crois qu'il y a pas de
marchandage aujourd'hui
à partir du moment où le référendum peut
intervenir que sur les jeux de société
je le dis c'est pas la solution la
dissolution quand on a une France
tripartite on voit bien que la
dissolution n'apporterait pas de
solution demain de gouvernement la seule
solution c'est d'avancer sur des sujets
qui intéressent les Français sur
lesquels ils attendent j'ai toujours dit
que c'est pas les grandes lois qui
mettent en colère les gens enfin qui les
gens la colère ils ont ils sont en
colère sur leur quotidien et moi je
connais pas un gouvernement qui a autant
agi sur le quotidien depuis 6 ans
présent je crois qu'il faut continuer à
agir sur le quotidien pour les voix qui
viennent remaniement moi je pense que le
chef de l'État était clair il donne 100
jours à la première ministre pour
pouvoir trouver la loi pour voter des
textes essayons d'y avancer une
réflexion je vois des républicains un
des républicains qui sont
partisans de j'allais dire
tu es la République telle qu'on la
connaît je vois des socialistes qui
souhaitent aussi ne pas aller vers les
filles est-ce que quand on voit les
sondages d'aujourd'hui ils sont pas
capables de réfléchir pour qu'il y ait
un grand bloc central capable de faire
avancer le pays c'est la question que je
leur pose donc vous les appelez à
travailler avec vous voilà merci
beaucoup François Patriot d'avoir été
notre invité possible du jour merci
beaucoup Fabrice wesser Redon d'avoir
représenté les journaux du groupe Ebra
de l'Est de la France on est bien Julie
le bien public tous les jours tout de
suite le club des territoires